hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und heute gibt es eine neue folge
wie schmeckt wie ihr schon im titel
lesen konntet machen wir heute die
pralinen aus dem film forrest gump wer
diesen film noch nicht gesehen hat es
gibt da eine ganz bekannte szene und
zwar sitzt service samt eines schönen
tages auf einer bank und sagt dass das
leben wie eine schachtel pralinen ist
denn man weiß nie was drin steckt
natürlich habe ich kein rezept wie jetzt
die forrest gump berlin genauer
schmecken sollten aber ich habe mir das
kleines überlegt was man für diese
forrest gump berlin auf jeden fall
branche geladen hohlkörper als ich die
auf amazon gesehen habe musste ich sie
einfach diese pralinen hohlkörper sind
rund und haben oben ein loch da kannst
du die füllung gerne rein machen und das
ist super einfach und wir lieben ist
supereinfach und jetzt fragt ihr euch
aber vanessa womit befüllen wir denn die
pralinen hohlkörper nichts leichter als
das sagte fredy vanessa zuerst noch mehr
ein mixer die mir meine mama zum
geburtstag geschenkt hat toyota den mir
geschenkt um musik zu machen aber
smoothies genau ich wollte die sache so
einfach wie möglich machen und deswegen
werden dass hier die füllung sah raffael
amicelli und erdnussflips erdnussflips
ich dachte mir wenn das leben wie eine
schachtel pralinen ist dann ist manchmal
was leckeres drin
und manchmal so was wie airbus fliegt
aber ohne scheiß ich kann mir echt nicht
vorstellen dass diese erdnussflips
berliner richtig gut am ende schmeckt
wir werden sehen sprach der blinde zu
meinen lehrern früher immer gesagt es
eigentlich voll diskriminierend und mein
gott ich habe mein leben lang gesagt
ohne zu merken was das für nen spruch
ist ich finde gesagt mit den raffaels
anfangen denn das wird bestimmt akkus
ist die besten aus kokosnuss ist die
beste nutzte das dass michael und ich
mach da ganz kleinen schuss sahne auf
damit dass so ein bisschen weniger wird
hoffentlich deckel drauf oh mein gott es
geht ja sofort los
wurdet es sie unsere füllung es nicht
die schönsten aber wir lieben sie in
ihren inneren wert die füllung mache ich
jetzt in dieses gerät hier rein und dann
dafür würde erst berlin
okay die erste was ich probieren
schmeckt gar nicht so schlecht ich will
mir das jetzt hier hin und dann völlig
so ein paar stück und hier habe ich
jetzt die ersten zwei reihen gefüllten
ist schon ein bisschen schwieriger als
ich dachte aber es geht trotzdem noch
nie fertig jetzt ein kühlschrank und
dann geht es schon an die nächste
füllung armut los so hier haben jetzt
die amicelli und die werden jetzt gemixt
[Musik]
sich auf kriege es einfach nicht auf ich
bin eine frau und stark ich schaffe das
los und mit charlie masse fülle ich
jetzt auch die nächsten quali so sieht
das bis jetzt aus und die bank wieder in
den kühlschrank und dann geht es an die
popcorn füllung des pop kunst erklären
ich jetzt aber nicht mit dem mixer ich
will gar nicht wissen was dann passiert
ich mache hier mit mit einem mörser
hierfür den popcorn in diesem jahr sei
zu klein möchte ich es auch nicht machen
weil ich möchte dass man noch zu dieser
kranke hat und nicht eine probierte
masse das funktioniert richtig gut
[Musik]
das wird jetzt eine kleine fummelarbeit
denn ich versuche das kleine popcorn in
die pralinen rhein zu füllen und es wird
interessant ich versuche jetzt einfach
mal
es ist mir ein bisschen was übergelaufen
kein ganz kleines bisher aber ansonsten
habe ich genug gefühlt also die prollige
warriors of rock hits wie den
kühlschrank und dann machen wir die
erdnussflips füllungen ja und zum
schluss füllen wir auf diese masse in
die praline hohen körper alle berlin
sind jetzt gefüllt und das bringt uns zu
unserem nächsten schritt für schritt
nummer zwei müssen wir was aufkochen
denn wir machen ein wasserbad denn das
wasser kocht müssen die es ausmachen
ich will jetzt das wasser in einen
großen topf und packen den kleinen topf
darüber wie kleine schoko drops gekauft
oder so so schoko plättchen die will ich
jetzt in den kleinen topf wir holen
jetzt unsere pralinen studium ist ein
bisschen dumm was weiß es an dem tag
anzuziehen wenn ich die mit schokolade
arbeite als erstes will ich ein bisschen
schokolade das loch oben rein damit das
popcorn nicht rausfällt wenn ich den
sohn ist romano belzig versteht ihr als
meine ja ich hab jetzt jedes noch mit
schokolade gestoppt und werde dass man
den küchen packen damit ein bisschen
aushärten kann und dann gucken wir sie
komplett rein
ich mache jetzt in diese pommes schale
ein bisschen schokolade und dann nehme
ich so eine praline
da nehme ich mir eine gabel und rolle
die praline durch die sprint und dann
nehme ich sehr aus der judith our first
praline und hier sind sie unsere vier
praline und du weißt nicht was drin
steckt hatte stern.de co noch vergessen
die passiert zum allerletzten mal in den
kühlschrank damit die schokolade schon
fest wird und dann geht's an die
geschmackstest ihr könnt ihr sehen ich
habe alle prall mit schokolade überzogen
ich habe es geschafft ich bin so kaputt
hier sind unsere pralinen alle vier
geschmacksrichtungen man kann diese
suppe auch zur weihnachtszeit
verschenken und entweder ihr passiert
eine pralinenschachtel oder ihr benutzt
wie ich breche typen die man überall
bekommt ja jetzt müssen uns aber da
aller wichtigsten frage stellen wie
schwierig und ich weiß nicht welche
welches ich hab's vergessen das leben
ist wie eine schachtel pralinen wobei
freemont denkt praline nummer eins
amicelli füllung anbieter lieber eine
gute idee
das ist die mit raffaello die schmeckt
auch super gut okay jetzt habe ich nur
noch popcorn und erdnussflips welches
welche ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
richtig lecker meine damen und herren
die erdnussflips praline band im lebens
nicht alles immer nur süß und schön
manchmal das leben auch scheiße zu teuer
vor lecker scheiße also wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste wäre popcorn auf
erster stelle mit kelly auf zweiter
danach erdnussflips und danach kaffee
dann hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte
gedacht es andersrum denkt dran kinder
zur weihnachtszeit da soll man sich lieb
haben und ich habe euch alle ganz doll
lieb und wir sehen uns dann beim anderen
video wenn euch dieses video gefallen
hat dann gibt mir bitte einen daumen
nach oben
und ach so ganz wichtig denkt dran
ihm ist die glocke an machen wenn ihr
nicht verpassen wollt das neue videos
kommen das ist echt so schlimm dass man
das mittlerweile sagen muss na gut bis
dann